Madam Deputy speaker in the face of
enormous challenges I report today on a
British economy which is proving the
doubters wrong
in the Autumn we took difficult
decisions to deliver stability and sound
money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked the international
monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
the
possibility forecasts
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
[Applause]
they
they forecast we will meet the prime
minister's priorities to have inflation
reduce debt and get the economy growing
We are following the plan and the plan
is working